[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: This
quickstart shows you
how to use Cloud Build
to build a Docker image
and push the image to
Container Registry.
You will first build the
image using a Docker file
and then build the same image
using a configuration file.
Before you begin, make sure
you have a Google Cloud
project selected and that you
have installed and initialized
the Cloud SDK.
Begin by running gcloud auth
login in the command line
to authorize a gcloud
command line tool
to access your project.
Use gcloud config set project
to connect the gcloud tool
with your project.
Now we'll create a simple Hello
World example and a Docker
file.
Cloud Build allows you to build
a Docker image using a Docker
file.
We don't require a
separate build config file.
First, we'll create a
script for our container
to execute called quickstart.sh.
Next, we'll create a
file called Docker file.
Finally, in the
command line, we'll
make sure that
quickstart.sh is executable.
In the directory where
the Docker file is,
use the gcloud
build submit command
with the tag flag set to the
project name and image name
you want to create.
If you have not enabled
the Cloud Build API,
you will be prompted
to do so now.
You've just built a Docker
image using a Docker file
and pushed the image
to Container Registry.
Let's build the same image using
a cloudbuild.yaml config file.
In the same directory that
contains quickstart.sh
and the Docker file, create
a file named cloudbuild.yaml.
This build config instructs
Cloud Build to perform tasks
based on your specifications.
After we've built
cloudbuild.yaml,
we'll use the gcloud
builds submit command
with the config cloudbuild.yaml
flag to build our image
and push it to
Container Registry.
Once we've built the
image and pushed it
to Container Registry, we
can use the Google Cloud
Console to view
the build details
on the Cloud Build page.
Once there, you will
see the build history.
By clicking on a
specific image, you
can see the details
of that build.
Now you've built
a container image
and pushed it into a
Container Registry, where
it can be used with other
parts of the Google Cloud Build
process.
[MUSIC PLAYING]